eyes on another
Target
eyes on the
third target number
[Music]
[Applause]
five
[Music]
careful they're on to
you we got an ombre
engaging
driving got the
[Music]
bike eyes on a second
target getat that [__]
fore
spe
attacking
I'll
pilot
realiz we got a PC over here there's a
record of the prison
in be an behind those walls let's move
we got a
PC good shooting let's clean up and move
on
sniper I'm here at the drop
zone
[Music]
I landed
I'm on the
ground take
[Music]
cover that's got to be the ward Z
us
[Music]
God damn
it
get
[Music]
down
enemy
[Music]
down Tango
down
the [__] incoming Mort fire [__] took
you so
[Music]
long
to the music that Mak
over
[Music]
let's
go
[Applause]
[Music]
for
foreign
spee
[Music]
fore
foree
[Music]
Lun
spee
it's DJ P smacking you in the air mus
that you can
handle when you hear the song of the
Dayle enemy activity stay sharp to
lovely
Sano once a Haven for the Qatari 26
Rebel beautiful Sano has been taken over
by La plaga and thanks to new security
measures cartel members can even walk
the streets of pictures Rosario without
ear explored San's beautiful canyons and
enjoyed long afternoon's knocking El
poalo also known as the stew
maker sometimes the cartel needs a dead
body to completely disappear Without a
Trace in such cases they ship the cavers
off to San
Mato last year more than 300 people
disappeared in San Mato the first thing
elero does is place the bodies inside a
drum Barrel which he fills with costic
soda sodium hydroxide after 24 hours
there's nothing left but a thick sludge
a
stew the only one who knows what truly
happened to these people is El poalo the
monster who melted
them